Yeah,
Rita dove
title,
professor of English,
I guess
you know,
when I read
this sounds really weird,
but when I was about 10 or 11,
I stumbled across the Elliot at home.
My father had bought the great books of
the Western world and one of the first
books there was the elliot.
I had no idea what it was,
but it was a very long thing and I
thought this is the beginning of
literature,
so I'm going to read this and I
understood probably about half of it,
but it was fascinating.
It was an incredibly tense and
interesting story and once I got into
the whole
way that the poems worked,
it were like a,
like a swash buckling mystery in a way.
So that made me feel like,
gosh,
this is exciting.
I'd like to do that too.
The one that I remember,
I wrote posts before this,
but the one that I consider first real
poem was about that time too,
but it was an easter poem.
Um,
in school we were supposed to write,
write,
or paint or do something artistic for
Easter.
So I wrote this poem called the rabbit
with the droopy ear and I remember it
because when I began writing the poem I
had no idea how it was going to end.
I just had this idea of a rabbit,
the Easter bunny who had one ear that
you know,
droop down and he was distressed.
So I kept writing and it rhymed and all
that,
and it was actually the rhyme itself
that helped me solve the problem of a
rabbit with the droopy year.
So the end of the poem that goes hip,
hip,
hooray,
let's toast the cup for now.
Both ears were hanging up,
he hanged himself from a tree and his
ears hang straight and everybody's
cheering.
And I was just,
I don't know,
it was very exciting to find that.
Indeed.
I actually had to read it aloud in
class,
you know,
that was another thing.
Those were the days when you did these
things in class,
but now people showed their paintings if
they had something from eastern.
I had to read my poem aloud and,
and people liked it,
the kids liked it,
my friends.
So that was an instant success story.
It hasn't totally changed.
Um,
it,
it's changed in the sense that,
that,
uh,
to some extent I know let's say that the
goal is not to come to some kind of neat
solution as that did,
but,
um,
but it hasn't changed in the sense that
at some level I'm never quite sure how
the poem is going to resolve itself and
that I'm always in some way surprise.
I make a discovery in a poem once I
write it a buy now that means more
accessing the subconscious and the fact
that if I begin writing a poem on that
means I'm intrigued in some way by
whatever it's about and that if I'm not
trying to find something new and pushing
that envelope in the poem,
I can't expect my reader to be
particularly excited about it either.
Um,
it's different every time.
And in fact,
years ago there was an,
I did do something like that,
uh,
for
a magazine.
Uh,
we're a,
we're a journalist actually followed me
around and we tried to.
But,
but I'm frightened different every time.
My inspiration comes from everywhere.
Uh,
just walking down the street just and I
never know where it's going to come
from,
so I keep a notebook with me at all
times.
Um,
and the only criteria for anything
making it into that notebook is if it
stops me in my tracks for even an
instant,
if it catches my eye or my ear,
you know.
And,
and I just write it down.
That means that there are recipes in
there,
you know,
there are words and sometimes there's a
character description or sometimes it's
aligned.
And after that point though,
what happens is kind of odd.
Um,
I tend to,
I work in fragments in the sense that
I'm not going to sit down and say,
first line is this,
and now I'm going to just write my way
through it.
I let the poem,
it's like piecing it together like a
pot.
So I might have a line that I might
write down on the middle of a page and I
still write things down with a pen on
paper.
I go to the computer when it gets too
messy and use it like an elaborate
typewriter because I've printed out.
And then I mess it up again,
but when I do get down,
sit down to write in my room with my
study and I try to write it a certain
time every night.
I'm a night person at best times or
midnight to six,
actually
I'll leave you my notebooks and if
something catches my eye and I feel like
I want to transfer it from the notebook
to the page I do.
And then comes this very strange
process,
which is difficult to describe and that,
uh,
right until I get stuck or I can't go
any further,
I'm boring myself or whatever.
And then I might go to another poem.
Uh,
I might go to another folder where there
are other drafts of poems and various
stages of completion.
And the only way I have for keeping
track of all this fragment tarry stuff
is by color.
And I have different colored folders,
red folders,
blue,
yellow.
So I might go into my study,
let's say one evening and say I feel
like the blue folder today
and I'll pick up the blue folder and see
what's in there.
So it's something that I've kind of
worked out over the years,
but the colors are only because I didn't
want to put anything.
I didn't want to file anything in a,
in a straight.
Um,
I think if you put something in a file
that says war poems or love pumps,
but you already restrict the way in
which the pole might move.
If I put it in blue,
it could be sad blue,
it could be happy blue,
it can be peaceful blue.
But my mood at the moment when I'm about
to work on that poem wants,
will,
will tell me where I want to go.
So it's an odd process,
but I do do lots of revisions and I love
to revise.
So 30,
40 revisions is not unusual at this
stage.
I do most of my revisions by myself
until I reach a point where I either
need to give it lots of time because
time is a great reviser to,
you know,
just months of,
of uh,
putting it aside or I will show it.
A lot of times I'll show it to my
husband who is a novelist and as a prose
writer,
he has a totally different take on
things.
So he comes at it a different way.
Um,
I yearned for those old days,
you know,
from graduate school and you go into a
workshop and people would give you all
these ideas and you take it away from
him.
But at this point,
um,
that just doesn't,
it's not in the current.
So
I think it's both.
I think that,
that you certainly don't have to be aged
and you know,
and,
and travel the world to write a poem,
in fact sometimes traveling the world
is,
is a way of not writing a poem,
but it's the quality of experiences
being able to,
to experience something.
And
when you begin to write about it,
be able to apply the tools that you need
for writing,
you know,
a mastery of the language in a way of,
of,
of piecing together the language.
I guess
that those two factors have to come
together.
So you do need to be to work at it,
but you also have to be able to know
when to,
when to take the experience as it
happened,
when to tweak it a little bit,
what part of the experience is going to
move somebody else or what part is
really your own private moment?
So I've,
I've seen poems written by very young
people which are absolutely stunning and
of course we have examples of bod layer
and wrote.
He was in his teens.
These were amazing poem.
So he obviously didn't have a wealth of
experience or age or anything like that.
And I've seen pumps which of course
could only have been written by someone
who was older and had lived a certain
stages of life,
have gone through certain stages of
life.
But it's a combination of the two really
is,
you know,
I,
I've always felt that the,
the poems I've written,
which have historical contexts
are hopefully not just simply plucking
something out of history and saying,
oh great,
let's write about that.
In every case,
what has happened is that I've become
fascinated or haunted by something and
couldn't shake it as an African
American,
as a woman,
I think that I've been sensitized to the
way of which history of privileges of
white male and the way in which certain
aspects of history,
the things that we are taught in school,
the things that are handed down,
never,
never entered the picture,
but they might've been very important.
Anyone can tell you that,
uh,
at the risk of over simplification,
let me say that anyone can tell you
that,
how you're raised as a child has a great
deal to do with how you behave as an
adult and,
uh,
whether you have complexes or whether
you need to prove yourself or all that
kind of stuff.
And yet
the mother in a traditional family who
has raised chuck never makes it in the
history books.
I mean,
and so,
so those kinds of things have always
irritated me.
Let's put it that way.
And I'm,
and I'm always reminded when I,
when I see someone,
Napoleon's stocks through the
battlefields.
And I think,
yeah,
but how do you get that way?
How this guy become who he was.
So that's,
that's the predisposition I have.
I think us as a writer,
as a person
who wanted to create poetry,
that's one of the things that has always
been one of my
things I carry along with me
each time is different.
For instance,
in this new book,
which is a tells the story of a,
of a black mixed race violin is George
Bridgetown who grew up in 18th and 19th
century Europe.
I came upon him because I was watching a
movie immortal beloved,
and there was a scene in which Beethoven
walks by a group of musicians and
there's this black violence on my,
what I've heard of color of my casting
because it's a bit strange.
And so I looked him up and the,
I didn't intend to write poems.
I above it.
Um,
I just wanted to know more about it and
I kept reading and the more I read,
the more I realized the only way I was
going to get him out of my head was to
get into his start writing down.
So in each case it's,
it's been something like that.
I think it's going to be a mix of
things.
What I find very interesting,
well first of all,
poetry of all the forms of literature I
think is the most suited for the digital
age and for the shorter attention spans
and all of that.
It,
it,
twitter's very easily some lyric pumps
and um,
it's very easy to zip up home to
someone.
So that's,
that's one of the things I think
wonderful
about poetry in the digital age.
I think that is going to be a mix
between people who will really only need
to see a book on a page and those who
will only want to hear on the stage.
I want to hear the hear the oral word.
What's interesting about the digital age
is because of all of the
ways in which we have of transporting
moving images now and making it very
portable.
The oral aspect of portraits coming back
in the portrait began as an oral
discipline and we had the printing press
and then it became gradually something
which,
uh,
began to lose a little bit of its
musicality because now we could read it.
So all of the rhymed pumps,
which,
you know,
all the formal homes,
which certainly began as a way of,
of,
um,
helping us remember a poem as an aid to
memory it,
that wasn't necessary anymore.
We moved away from that.
Now we have spoken word,
right.
It's coming back in.
So it's,
it's absolutely fascinating to me.
I think it's going to change a little
bit more,
become a little bit more musical and
we'll have a whole range of things.
But it's an exciting time.
My first advice would be to read,
read,
read it,
which sounds interesting coming in a
digital age,
but it's so much easier to listen to
upon it is to sit down and actually read
it and to hear it in your head.
And that's something that,
that every poet or aspiring poet needs
to be able to do anything to hear it in
their head.
What I wish someone had told me,
hmm,
I wish someone had told me that
my stories
are really mine to tell another with
anything that um,
I think is important or that that has
moved me,
has the ability to move somebody else.
It was a long process too for me.
And I think for many young poets to be
able to realize that even the smallest,
the most domestic,
uh,
experience can move someone else.
It doesn't have to be about,
um,
the Trojan war,
you know,
doesn't have to be the Elliot.
It doesn't,
uh,
it doesn't have to be something that,
again,
here,
we'll get to history that,
that makes it to the front page of the
news.
But we live our lives in detail.
All of us,
we walked down the street,
we breathe,
we hear things,
we try to transcribe it in generalities
and the details are what make us come
alive.
And I wish someone had said that just at
the beginning.
So I wouldn't have felt so discouraged
when I began writing and thinking who
would want to hear the stories of a
young black girl?
You know,
growing up in the Midwest,
you know,
that's not interesting.
I have to live in Paris.
No,
you don't.
I'm not thinking of my audience,
which does not mean that I'm doing it
for myself.
Uh,
I'm thinking at the very beginning when
I begin writing a poem,
I try not to think of the audience or
anyone at all except for trying to get
at the very center of what's driving
that poem.
Why,
why?
In a way it's like analyzing myself.
Why did I even sit down to write this?
Why is it even interesting?
What is it that drives this thing that
means excess assets in the that means
going down into the very deepest
psychological moments.
Things that can frightened and scare you
and I think that to think of an audience
at that point would actually drive those
thoughts away.
But during the process of revision and
what happens is that I'm thinking about
the language and how I can use the
language,
which is my tool to convey whatever this
experience slash emotion is so that if
anyone else sits down to read it,
they can also feel it.
So it's beyond just saying,
talking about describing something is
also using words would help to shape the
emotion so that if it's supposed to be
something very hectic
or a frantic moment,
then the words probably would be shorter
and clipped and
things like that.
During that revision process it becomes
less and less a private matter and
Baltimore,
something for an anonymous audience.
I don't try to imagine a an audience in
the sense of at that stage I don't try
to imagine the audience in the sense of,
well these are all educated people,
you know,
from the ages of 18 to 45.
I just think of there is someone out
there who might want to read this.
If they read this little bit.
I want to get them to feel the same
thing that I'm feeling and that's my
audience,
but that in the end I'm thinking only of
them and I'm not there.
It would be wonderful if we were
striving for toward a post racial
literature and certainly the election of
Obama is a big step on the way.
I think that we shouldn't get complacent
and think,
oh gosh,
now we're post racial.
We are not,
we haven't had the conversations we need
to have about race and privilege and all
of that stuff up.
We're starting,
so we're on our way,
but one of the things that I've always
dreamed of is to have a post racial
literature at you waste so much energy
and good a talent.
I'm either trying to insist upon your
presence,
which is certainly what happened in the
black arts movement in the sixties for
instance.
Uh,
and you also waste a lot of energy then.
I'm
sorry,
I lost my thought.
Well,
you wasted a lot of energy insisting
upon your presence,
but then you also can waste a lot of
energy explaining things,
explaining things which are specific to
your,
to a certain racial culture,
which if you think about it in terms of
the mainstream,
we don't mind looking things up if we
don't understand them,
but we kind of expect to be clued in on
various things that happened in,
in the culture.
One of the things that I've always found
frustrating are the little reference
points that
I might have to explain it,
a poem that I wouldn't have to explain
if it were in it,
if,
if it were a mainstream detail.
For instance,
I know exactly how a white woman would
do her hair every morning.
I know the washing and the blow drying
and all of that kinds of stuff.
But so that if I see that in a poem,
if it were to occur in a poem,
um,
then I would have problem with it.
Whereas for me to,
to even to get up and explain getting up
and rushing in and how to do my hair,
it would require all sorts of glosses.
You know,
I'd have to say,
well,
yes,
there's the,
there's the hair pomade and there's the
visit.
And uh,
and,
and so my hope is that in a,
in a post racial,
cultural,
all these kinds of details,
we will just assume that we can figure
them out.
And we will assume that that is
something as we read them,
that will,
we'll have to look up instead of
demanding that our writers,
um,
give us a gloss right in the middle of
the palm.
I think we're on our way.
It's so funny,
when I was poet laureate,
when I be,
when I was named poet laureate and went
down to Washington a little bit
beforehand to meet,
um,
the,
uh,
assistant and meet the Librarian of
Congress and all that into,
to kind of acclimate myself.
And I did ask what my duties were,
the only official duties are to a
sponsor,
a reading series at the library of
Congress twice a month and make sure
that.
So that was fun too,
to be able to invite poets from all over
the world actually to come to read and
to read for the archives.
That was wonderful fish.
Dory.
The other duty was to advise the library
of Congress,
the Librarian of Congress,
and also,
and this was the funny one,
to promote poetry in any way that I see
fit.
I said,
what does that mean to promote poetry?
And
I said,
well,
what's the budget because you're going
to promote you,
but,
and I got to kind of a blank stare.
So I thought,
okay,
this means that you make it up as you go
along.
What else?
The,
the,
you know,
I'm an artist I could create and I
decided to just do things,
um,
and fear they would stop me if they
didn't have enough money,
which was probably a good way to go
about it because they did find money
for,
for various things.
But what was interesting,
it's not a,
it's sort of like being Miss America for
poetry.
And that as a,
as the poet laureate,
you have an immediate,
um,
cache and you have some,
you have stairs,
people see you have some kind of
publicity,
some kind of a public stage.
And I thought of myself as being more
like a lightning rod.
People would say,
oh,
there's a poet laureate,
let's ask her or
tell her what to do.
And I got so many letters right from the
beginning,
from people all over this country.
He's telling me what I should do.
And some of them were really good ideas,
so,
and I couldn't implement all of them and
the time I was there,
the two years I was there,
the one thing that I found very,
very helpful was to remember that many
people are very frightened of poetry.
And as poet laureate,
I had a chance to travel around to just
inject poetry in to everyday life
whenever I could.
And so I visited grade school kids or
the naval academy and with all sorts of
places where,
where you thought,
you know,
didn't know they liked poetry or poetry
was absolutely necessary.
So,
um,
each poet laureate decide kind of what,
how they want to use that public arena.
And I decided to to try to just
be there and people's faces whenever the
they turned around to make poetry
something that was all around us.
I went on Sesame Street for instance.
And,
and,
uh,
yeah,
it was really fun.
The other thing that happens with poet,
the poet Laureateship,
is that when you are.
When I was in Washington,
there was an opportunity to inject
poetry into the government.
And the other lawyer does not have to
write official poems or anything.
There were many occasions when I would
be asked to say a few words,
which is of course a kind of a euphemism
for,
to,
you have a poem was there's always a
poem.
You can always find a poem for almost
any human situation.
So I didn't write poems or for specific
events,
but,
um,
I could look and see if I had a poem
which would fit in that because I think
that it's always important.
It's important if,
if there's a celebration for some bill
being passed,
it's nice to have a poem there to remind
us all of the human element and the
human effort that went behind it.
So that was,
that was important to,
um,
the,
the Penguin Anthology of 20th century
American poetry
is a Gargantuan,
Gargantuan project.
And basically,
uh,
I'm trying to make sense poetically,
of the 20th century in America.
So it starts,
I'm really right there with 'em
at Arlington Robinson and it goes up
until anything published in the year
2000.
I'm trying.
So what the difference in the center
algae is instead of just a poem here
upon their two pubs where this person
trying to give a sense of of major
poets who then influenced other poets as
well,
so that we may be quite a few poems by
say let's choose someone William Carlos
Williams and then show how he influenced
all sorts of other poets who may have a
few other,
not as many poems in the oncology.
What makes a classic poem.
I think that when a poem can move
readers across
generations and across its specific
class or race,
then it becomes truly classic.
I mean,
in other words,
if the poem is so moving that even if
you have no experience in that
particular setting,
be it 19 twenties,
Harlem,
let's say you still are so moved that,
that,
that you can put yourself in that
position.
That means that the writer has managed
to go beyond the,
the,
the personal and,
and touch the humanity in all of us.
And it's been really a blast to read it
because I realized how,
um,
that this does hold true for the truly
great poems.
Oh Gosh,
no,
there's not a specific poem.
There they are,
it changes,
changes depending on the,
on the,
um,
what I'm working with,
where I'm at at the moment,
but
there are,
I mean,
they're just poems that are just so
amazing to me.
Um,
and I,
and if I named one that I course lose
another,
but,
but it,
it goes in and out,
I think that.
Hmm,
let me think.
I can't name a specific one lines flow
through my head.
There's a,
a very beautiful German poem by Gerta,
which I often say to myself because it's
like a little prayer and uh,
but it's also totally untranslatable
I've never been able to translate it.
And um,
it's humbling because you realize the,
we need translators.
Please,
please,
we need our translators.
Otherwise we'll never have any of these
posts,
would never know who,
how bottom layer moves us or anything
like that.
But you also realize how much gets lost,
how,
how necessarily poetry is so bonded to
the,
to the language in which it is composed
that it's,
you're,
you're always going to lose.
And I find that very humbling.
Um,
so
yeah,
but it's a wonderful woman that rhymes,
but it rhymes in odd ways about other
gifts
and I live vip spirit.
His Stu calm.
I'd how Baltimore binder who was out.
That's it.
And you can hear the rhymes and
basically transfer it.
It says overall the mountains.
Tranquility
rests
in all of the tips of the trees and
that's VIP for which is a great little
winter.
All the tops of the trees you can.
You can hardly feel a breath.
Wait.
Just wait.
Soon.
Youtube will rest.
And it's just,
it's because of the minds that make this
such a calm and it's just in certain
words that totally untranslatable like
vip,
which does mean tips of the trees,
but that doesn't sound very good in
English,
but it,
it's,
it's almost rocks you to sleep and I
just find it incredibly amazing poem
tightness.
And yet tranquility
could let me think.
What could I do a longterm?
I'll read one,
I'll read a short one and a,
but I have to give you a little gloss
for it.
I'm
in.
This poem is from my new Book Sonata
Melodica,
which tells the story of George Bridge
Tower,
a Mulatto violinist from the 18th and
19th centuries.
In this poem,
he was a prodigy.
He's a little boy,
10 years old in England playing his
violin in front of all of the music
lovers of London,
and his father is sent back,
sent away from London.
The Prince of Wales says,
I'll take care of the little boy,
and so you have this little boy who is
has the best job in the world for a
musician,
but at the same time he has no family,
and in this poem the prince has ordered
him to go into as women to change into
British clothing.
The undressing
first,
the sash peacock,
blue silk unfurling round and round
until I'm the India ink darting a called
British.
Now I can bend to peel off my shoes,
try to hook the tasseled tips into the
emerald sales of my set and pantaloons
fair.
Well sir,
monkey jacket,
monkey red,
a do shirt,
tart and bright as the lemons.
The prince once.
Let me touch goodbye.
Lakeside metal,
goodbye hummingbird throat.
No more games.
I am to become a proper British
gentlemen cuffed and buckled with
breaches and I find Krevak,
but how my tossed bedclothes while I.
I am a smudge acquainted wick.
A twig shrouded in snow.